there it is good morning everyone
welcome back to gamespot live i'm richie
and you know what that means it's call
of duty day let's go how's everyone
doing
thank you for joining me so early um
i'm here on the west coast it is 6 a.m
please in the comments in the chat tell
me where you're from i love hearing it
and i really appreciate you being here
so early
um so we're going to play some call of
duty vanguard of course today is the day
we got a little
early a bit of an early launch day
so let's just jump in i'm gonna start
the campaign
and then um
if if the servers are around and um
available i'll try some multiplayer but
it's kind of a weird time so let's you
know not everyone's online but we'll try
first things first though campaign let's
get into it
look at all these missions i was playing
i've cleared the campaign because uh
you know we're we're we were in the
review period
so i got to play the whole thing let's
just start from the beginning
9 a.m in new york city hey thanks for
being here all right 9am where i'm at
hey what's up chat i see you guys in
chat for
gamespot trailers and game spots youtube
page thanks for being here let's do it
hardened is good enough for me that's
like the perfect middle ground uh maybe
even regular for stream so i'm not
looking so so bad so busted let's just
try regular
nazi germany
the final push into the heart of
darkness
the so-we had recruited the six of us
under my command for one reason
to retrieve files on the top secret
project phoenix the last gasp of the
third reich
a coalition of allied commandos thrown
together
and aimed at where our enemy was most
vulnerable
this was meant to be
her first and only mission
would you look at that
who's up for saving it
let's go
here we are baby task force one beating
up every nazi on this train already look
at that all right it's kind of a sneaky
mission though
um and i'll cut out for the cut scene so
you guys can see because they're they're
the pre-rendered cutscenes are so nice
and you guys should just enjoy them
here we go
looking good looking good all clear
move up
check this out
paulina don't mess around um
they wrote her so well let me scoot up
here
yeah paulina will be on top up here on
the train like looking out because she's
the sniper like the whole time it's
really cool
whoops sleep too hard sleep too hard
ooh check out this fool
locked and loaded that's right jay
oh this guy's dead
goofed up that's like me
disoriented just with my coffee like oh
good coffee though
word
she sniped the other one there she is up
there
posted up
okay this door's locked so i'm gonna go
around
that's me i'm novak
sdg
revolk i like both although the recoil
is higher on this but i'll take it
oh bad dude
so we are supposed to hijack this train
so far it's going good
got him
shoot
pauline excuse me
they already oh crap oh i fell off the
train all i had to do was stay on the
damn train cj
let me move my mic here
there we go i think
i'm i nudged my camera a little bit like
this earlier this week whatever y'all
don't need to see me man they pushed me
back so far
okay not that far
just like deja vu
crap
i left the you know
for those who have a playstation 5 you
might know that the triggers do that
thing
uh it's like a you know it's like a
vibration thing it's pretty fun in this
game
um and i usually don't leave it on but
i've left it on this whole time it's
pretty fun
check it out going full blown lmg here
with the car 98
oh i'll take this
now i like my silence one i'll keep this
later on there's an mg i'll we'll pick
it up then
how long is the campaign and when does
the review drop great questions campaign
let's see
is a little longer than normal i would
say like
well i don't know it depends how you
like to play i think it took me
um
six and a half hours something like that
i like to explore though
uh the review
is currently being written i don't have
the final date on that but it should be
soon
but it wasn't done my b by me so i don't
um you know i'm not writing it i'm not
exactly sure
nice that's one way to deal with the
truck
chad says well ai's still dumb af yep
make me look good that's how dumb they
are
look at all this gold
all these guns let's see maybe but i
like i like the selection i have
um but this cool it's cool they give you
the option like in the first level very
fun
take the mp40 when you can it's always
overpowered yeah it is i just like this
this uh sten this stein or whatever
because uh it's silenced and i'm trying
to keep it trying to keep it quiet oh
never mind anymore look at this
okay next time i do see the mp40 i'll
get it just for you friend
[Music]
okay come on slow down here
there we go
this version of the car 98 has 20
rounds in the magazine it's called the
trench magazine
it's gonna be the hottest thing mark my
words of course why not you know
everyone loves this gun everyone loves
more bullets
there goes uh wade
i'll let him handle this truck watch
this
there he is up there
yeah wade is a cowboy for sure
sounds like shorter than world war world
war ii and about the length of cold war
i think that sounds about right i can't
confirm i played i played through cold
war like you know once or twice i guess
i don't remember
but it's good i wouldn't say you know i
would say it's like averagely call of
duty maybe a little longer
oh that's the mg i should have picked up
whatever
holy crap paulina
what up
[Laughter]
that enemy was low poly dude he was
looking like um
a james bond bad guy from n64
i haven't seen that the whole time
that's interesting
oh crap there's two of them here i
forgot
see here i am shooting my own teammates
being careless
come on kingsley
you know they're the same way they
behave the same way on veteran mode they
you know their bullets just do more
damage
you know i'm just now noticing that
is that the same dude yelling at the
orchestra
no no that's courage i'm not courage
uh yeah but if you caught that
call of duty presentation last night
that was wild let me know if you guys
caught it and what you think
uh because
it was
so funny and it was off the rails
i couldn't
i couldn't even focus man
um it was so fun
professional maybe not but hilarious
entertaining
uh a mess yeah sure
we fighting oh there he is
how many this guy
is he wearing here will it prove best
oh man on the other side i should have
ah never mind oh check this out guys
that i thought i'd kill that guy i'm
tripping
i'm shooting the truck and the driver
okay
anyway check this out
what's my fov like 0.5 i don't remember
um i think it's automatically set to
100.
you know i keep it 100 right here on
gamespot i'm just kidding i'll check
after this that's a good question
okay everyone's oh
is everyone dead yeah that guy's
my teammate is killing that dude all
right let's check fov because
it is um
you can change it in the game and you
can change it in multiplayer
i forget where
controller gameplay
probably an interface or audio no not
audio um interface
where is it man i don't remember i might
have to back out of this
but i am interested look at that
scrub
where on earth
i probably skipped it um it's no big
deal i
i was able to change it yesterday i
guess i
you know
i don't remember
maybe it was only in um
no that's not right i was gonna say
maybe it only was in multiplayer
because i changed it to a hundred
i think it defaulted to no i think it
was at a hundred i don't remember
anyway i hope it's not uh ruining your
enjoyment
die
there we go
okay we are still trying to hijack this
train from all the bad dudes it's we're
getting there
okay don't know how i did that that was
pretty dope
uh but early thoughts guys let me know
what you guys think of the uh
the gameplay so far and um
you know
uh i was wondering if you're uh maybe
pick this up you know you're here for a
reason you're here joining us today
uh i assume for a reason of some
interest you know just to check it out
um i'm having fun with it so far myself
but you know we got to see when more
people get online how it
what am goes doing i have this
holy crap
lucas
torch that dude
all my friends are on the other side i
gotta go i gotta go
put richie on cdl god here oh my god
i mean i can go up against little john
maybe but i am not a
a good player in general and it's just
kind of funny because i love call of
duty so much
i have fun though you know i keep i keep
it at about a 1k d you know i'm one of
those but uh
campaign makes me look good you know
check this out
[ __ ] me dead
now that would be properly shot at
mike the officer in charge tell us what
the hell we're doing here
that submarine base is our final stop
once we're in we move to secure the
objective he wants us to secure it but
he won't tell us what it is kingsley's
been dancing around there since the
get-go this ain't just another easter
egg hunters here mate what's a bloody
story we don't quite know
you mean the so [ __ ] he doesn't quite
know you know what i'm gonna go pull the
bricks all we have is a name
phoenix
so we got no idea what we're up against
that's the mission
to find out
soe says the krauts are moving something
big out of germany
could be a document stash
the holiest of holies
we are here to pinch it if this is so
important why did they not send an army
they did
there's six of us mate we're not from
the same army hell we're not even from
the same continent quiet get back
why were we chosen for this [ __ ]
suicide mission
brass hand-picked six specialists hit
the crowds fast and get away clean an
army can't do that too loud too slow
[ __ ] right they won't see us coming
in and out with those papers before they
know it
do we understand the plan
i shoot nazis they die
that's my plan
and we're back baby
paulina has the best line she's like i
kill nazis that's my job
let's see here things are about to get a
little heated so i think i will take
this
nicely placed mg 42.
oh we're also we're sneaking we're
sneaking
oh no dogs forgot
man
someone else kill them i don't want to
shoot the dog shoot the people
oh
no more
okay i didn't have to kill him i still
had to hear him
almost shot arthur in the face
okay i think i saw in the chat when does
it officially come out um
call of duty activision they said you
can play
you know it was supposed to launch on
the fifth uh they said you can play on
the fourth at
uh 9 p.m i believe i'm playing it early
because like they they allowed us to
play even earlier like at 6am today but
uh otherwise they said for everyone else
if you bought it pre-ordered it and all
that stuff you can play
[ __ ] i ran right into that grenade
uh you can play tonight at 9pm i believe
it the
install will be ready to go
you treat her like female woods with
that one's liners and stuff yeah i mean
she's got plenty of one-liners she's
still badass though just like woods i
love woods
and later on she talks a lot more
because there's a pretty big story and
it's uh i hope we get there
what the the dog got me with the dog
doing
can't believe it
i was i was aiming up
dog went right for you know not up he
went he got me
no i want the car 98 let's see here yeah
there we go
man i was doing good too oh well got to
be you got to be aware of dogs
all right gary thanks for dropping by
uh come back i'll be uh playing a little
later if you're if you change your mind
this first mission is a little quiet but
it gets nuts pretty soon
i hear him
no not again
yes sir
here we go
damn dude is lighting me up
i would have been dead on veteran mode
already
where is he
he's blind firing dude i still don't
like to do that i don't i'm not very
good at i mean i know it's a risk but it
never it has never once paid off for me
at blind firing
all right i'm getting ready for that dog
again
there they are oh man
don't look
take out that sniper
man what sniper just kidding
everyone inside
wow
did they take care of that sniper or did
i really get them let's go
oh here we go
here we go round two
oh
no think we're good i'm gonna reload you
guys cover me
pretty good sir
if you buy the game now will you be able
to play it editor nope you will be able
to play it
at nine o'clock your time at night
tonight we got the chance to play it
early but
um
you know it officially launches on the
on the fifth technically i'm sorry not
technically on the fourth tonight they
they allowed people to to load up their
i think digital copies
dude they're running away
let's see here
anyone else
i was trying to pick up an mp40 for chat
but of course since the
since someone in chat requested that i
haven't found one that's how it goes
get in there
task force one man
jackson get the door
we missed a hell of a party looks like
they left in a hurry
here we go we must be close not for long
crowds are moving their stash onto a sub
you see that lot lugging that chest i
bet you london to a brick that is what
we're after
so what are we waiting for time to bring
the heavy stuff now we're talking wait
we can't go in loud
arthur
whatever's in those papers is the best
kept secret in the third reich and the
crowds kept them here in the ass end of
nowhere so what it makes no sense it's
like leaving the crown jewels on the
front porch with hardly anyone watching
them
the entire german army should be
guarding this place
we're not the only ones who don't know
what phoenix is
you're saying nazis are keeping secrets
from nazis i'm saying the ones in charge
of the secrets are the most dangerous
yeah that's why we brought the guns you
shoot them
are we done here those papers are about
to piss off out of germany you three
take the catwalk and make your bloody
noise bias time web novak you're with me
we'll take the boat
clear
all right so our first clue
we went into this not knowing much just
we had a name project phoenix that was
it let's get intel on project phoenix
little by little we'll get there
[Music]
do i trade a good scope or do i keep the
20 round magazine i think i'll stick
with the 20 round magazine say goodnight
oh the guys already did
they're everywhere
i keep missing there we go there's a
good one
see i would have had to reload so much
by now
how did i get to play um activision sent
us the code to review oh [ __ ] i shot my
friend to review the game you know so we
get it a little early and then they said
on
on the morning of the fourth you can
play
so they officially allowed us to but
it's not open to everyone yet you know
just a media outlet thing
but they allowed us to stream it for
everyone
that's great uh because here we are it's
six in the morning where i'm from uh
here on the west coast
and they were like yeah you can play
early and i was like okay
i'm not gonna say no to that
okay okay here i come i keep i'm
distracted
oh crap
oh shoot where was where were my friends
to help me with that look one's here
one's here and they're just waiting for
me to get killed
some friends
there we go oh wow
deja vu right from yesterday no
someone in the chat already called me
courage that's funny
how many more are there one more watch
okay great let's move on
this is actually
the call of duty hat they sent me i'm
wearing this the dog tags remember a
while back they sent out those care
packages i was so happy they sent me one
for the first time
what else
okay those are our friends on the
catwalk let's keep going keep
out of going
i saw him like the crate on that sub
cover us we're going aboard good luck
kids i'll find us a way out of here
oh you want me to go first fine
oh yeah sorry peter this is a ps5
i died here a lot because the bullets
can
ricochet and they kept killing me like
instantly when i dropped down there i
think they patched that out i swear i
kept i got killed here like
10 times in a row yesterday just trying
to play
poor timing to reload
that was
oh well we're here
i wasn't i wasn't checking my ammo oh my
god the steam
you're all right
i'm good baby
stay close
all right go come on
they're all panicking of course oh my
god you still alive
oh maybe it was a stun
i can never be in a submarine for that
long i'm pretty i'm
like a little claustrophobic and this
would do it for me
of course arthur i got you brother let's
see here
so it looks like the avengers a almost
that's scary
they dealt with nazis too
either
steven says what time can we play on
xbox series x
uh
tonight at 9 00 pm i believe
oh
wait
is
australia again
i know so
you
get up with it i delightfully you think
you're british
a cambridge man through and through
so
you know better than to
ruin a man's evening
beethoven's fault sonata has exquisite
but demanding passengers that deserve my
full attention
unlike you
does the negro give orders in english
ah
please
proceed
your rhineland accent
you must be from neustadt
during the occupation
you saw french soldiers who look like me
carry guns in your streets
marry your women
that's what i hear
when you speak german
join me
we thrashed you once
hear those bombs
that's us thrashing you again
what an interesting choice of words
i told you already
get on with it
yeah
that's what you are
to sacrifice yourself
to be a
leader
i'm not here to give you what you want
quite a
you concert your mother
disposal that
put the rest in the truck
jesus christ
people die
people die when command [ __ ] up
how exactly is this arthur's fault
this is on him
and on wade
abandoning his team
well you're right about wait
if he shows his face again i'm bloody
killing myself oh yes let's keep blaming
each other instead of the germans
is that supposed to impress me relax
it does not matter
verizon is going to kill us all
surprisingly
the nazi the one who kills novak old
friend of yours is he
we have history oh yeah what caught it
against fryzinger
arthur will get us out of this
what because he's your mice
it wasn't always
but i've seen them in action
you lose men
that's war
sometimes the only way to honor a fallen
soldier is to finish the mission
but try remembering that while their
blood stains your boots
if you're meant to lead you have to
learn what it's like to lose men
to have them die trusting you
and there's only one way to learn that
lesson
first time i did
was on d-day
and it seems like the crowds already
know we're coming
now we've got one chance to demolish the
coastal artillery but if we don't the
invasion of tomorrow will fail now i
change you all for this
let's not let the navy show us up
so take the case mates
blast the artillery and fire flare so
let them make you know the job's done
all right this is it
you know the drill
stand up
hook in
oh
ugh
uh
thank you
oh
that was rough
well i'm back that was a lot of
cutscenes i hope you guys enjoyed
uh those are always fun and they look
they look great to me um but here i am
i'm stranded
no weapon
my friends are gone everything's on fire
let's get to the windmill
did you guys see this when they i think
this was like the first bit of gameplay
they ever showed was this operation
tonga level
i just got to beat got to keep it cool
got to keep it quiet got to keep it
stealth
dude get that flashlight out of my face
who cares for cod says harold hey man
you clicked the video you know we want
you here but
you don't care if you don't care
i can't change your mind for you
but it's a special day it's
cod launch day a little early but
we're here
it is going down out there i'm gonna
see here
oh he's calling out flash
oh
okay how dare you
[Music]
first guy down
is this the least cod uh least hyped cod
of all time i'm not sure man
um
this week has been
a lot of call of duty for me so i'm
feeling the hype but
i don't know people are indifferent
about world war ii games you know
they made them they made call of duty
world war ii games for like 10 years you
know people were people
a lot of people just didn't want to play
them anymore
but uh i'm hyped and i hope you're at
least having a good time today on stream
let's see if we can find our friends
or anyone that's not a nazi
oh
great
if they see me i'm toast i have two
bullets
they saw me i can't believe it i was not
being stealth
screwed
well they're being really lousy shots so
maybe i can just run away
let's look at this
yeah
see
i was really being quiet i was trying
oh well i got seven bullets
where is it
okay this light is right in my face and
this level is very dark
excuse after excuse
okay
oh you know what he's above he's above
he's above
yeah i'm gonna get out of here for a sec
go go go go go
okay guys
oh my god
okay
yeah even the game's like yo go over
here i just want this guy dead
shot his foot thank goodness that's over
okay
i did go this way i just didn't open the
door all right
here we go
oh
holy crap that blew him back
i should really take cover
i keep not taking cover
it's okay
i haven't died yet
oh i'll take that mp40 yeah
sure can i have them both yeah
all right let me reload this thing
and get back into action
i knew it i knew they threw a grenade i
heard like tick
oh i almost had him
is that it no
way okay clear for now let's go
oh goodness gracious
that can't be good
oh got one
two
there we go
oh no
i heard a dog they sneak up on you man
i'm gonna hide back here a little bit
same there's the dog no
come on reconsider killing me dog
bad boys
aic through walls yeah
yeah dude was
you were shooting me through the the
floorboards wait
was that is that a special different
scope i think yeah i'll take it someone
is picking on me dude there's no scope
here i read that wrong
oh
never mind okay
i'll stick with the uh the old car 98
that i know
i finally did get the mp40 though
come on
that better be it i gotta move
okay very good
yeah i'll take that ammo let's go
there's the windmill that's where i have
to go
was that a rabbit i think it was i saw
one earlier
we are here oh my god it's in bad shape
he was gonna bayonet me
yo it is crowded in here i just i just
stormed this door like i knew what i was
doing
crap i think there's one more
right
nope guess not
oh
it's right here
good thing i'm not on veteran mode dude
i would have died embarrassingly so i
was like close is clear
got killed
thunder thunder don't shoot
don't shoot damn you kingsley we picked
you as a crowd lucky we didn't fill you
full of lead
and that's the story of how i met
richard webb
nice to see you gents where do we stand
the captain didn't make it so we're on
our own now
i say we dig in and wait for the rest of
the sick airborne to assemble henry said
we have till dawn to destroy the
artillery if we don't the invasion fails
so you fancy yourself the captain now
sun-up's an hour away at best there's no
time for a sit down there's also no
muscle no cavalry coming to save the
bloody day
the only thing we could do here is to
die or try not to you two scrapping over
who's got the bigger bollocks ain't
gonna solve nothing those german
casemates aren't that far away i think
we can get to them in time so why say we
take them out the company's scattered
we're pissing in the wind at this point
i know what's at stake
you all do this is madness hey we're
beyond madness
look i'm with arthur
we finished the mission
all right
looks like you're in charge now
casemates and valhalla
are that way
all right looks like i'm running things
uh got some questions in the chat yeah
this is ps5 um if you i believe if you
pre-ordered the a digital copy of the
game you can play at nine o'clock
pacific standard time starting today
they let us at gamespot play a little
earlier uh they let us play at 6am this
morning
um that's why i'm here that's why you're
seeing this now
let's get a paul but you should be able
to play tonight i believe if you
digitally pre-order
and yeah i'm on playstation 5. what is
project phoenix and what will happen if
the germans succeed in it
you'd want to know man that's actually a
big plot point that's the whole point of
this game was project phoenix
discovering what it is and
um you know why the germans are hiding
it
someone said incorrect mp40 reload i'm
sure you're right i don't know anything
about guns actually but that's
interesting that you pointed that out i
wonder how it was incorrect
watch this
maybe the full reload was incorrect but
uh either way that's interesting
tell me more
it's like
imagine playing this in 4k yeah
i think i can like get a screen
recording in 4k on the playstation 5 i
don't know i don't know how it runs
though on pc of course it'll look better
stay quiet and get close
thanks for being here you guys i know
it's a little early but um
we got to play call of duty a little
early today ourselves
got options okay cool i'm the shot
caller here let's go pick on that guy
right there
that guy's not falling back at all liar
oh well first area clear
whoa that a guy in an mg turret
yeah
no way
no way i got him from here cool that was
awesome
got him
another one on that half track
let me reload here
yo it is hot give me away from
all this mg gunfire i have to go in
though let me go around let me go around
scout
yeah let's go around
forget this
holy crap
come on peek your head
did they get that guy
nope
okay i'm a little closer let me i've
been using the car nine a lot uh and i'm
not even really a good sniper but
let's try the mp40 for a little bit here
let me get closer
anyone else
with fast mags sure
oh but 64 mags nah i gotta do it
attack
cool they can do it for me go go go
i guess not
oh wait one
nicely done they didn't do anything
though that guy's still alive
oh well
how we doing chad let me see here
do something about the sound uh is the
sound too low am i too high
let me know uh
let me know in the chat please i gotta
figure this out i almost killed this
dude
and that dude
what the
you guys came out of that room and
didn't kill that guy
sure i'll get the stg why not
that dude is posted up just hanging out
dude my teammates are scattered in with
the bad guys here i almost keep shooting
them come on guys
guys make me do the work oh he threw a
grenade oh
gamespot asmr that's funny
um it's early so i'm not trying to be
super loud
come on the attack won't show up anymore
that's not a head
this whiffed it
again but they're backing up they're
going away let's push let's push
they're all over there check this out
they're just ready to die
dude
they're just shuffling away where are
you guys going
hey watch out now
i'm trying to be loud sometimes new
story
sorry trying to keep up with the chat
appreciate you guys being here
another mg okay
do i have smoke grenades i think i do
let's go let's be tactical about this
i'm still getting lit up
keep that
down
little by little let's just keep pushing
the stream sounds great i don't know
what the other dude was talking about
okay
yeah the npcs are letting me be the star
that's pretty great i really do feel
like a leader of this group
pushing up pushing up
that's not enough space
oh no
dude
no i did not see him not bad
i can't get an inch on this
guy how did i do it before
i don't remember
i'm sl okay i'm slightly louder than the
video which is good okay good
arthur changed his voice he's like guys
seriously get the tower cutter
[Music]
yeah why not
check this out guys
nevermind don't check that out it'll
work
got him
good job man
that was cool
all right i think we'll switch into a
cut scene here so let me back up and you
guys enjoy
well that was a [ __ ] kerfuffle
hey sarge got it done
still here aren't we i suppose
eight men standing against the nazi
gunfort
richard said i got mad
sometimes
a little madness is called for i think
deep down he understood that
and realized
we were cut from the same cloth
they're waiting on you sarge
wonderful let's go i'm back
i like those breaks i can chat with you
guys in the chat and just like have a
sip of coffee there
uh it's early you know
i hope you guys enjoyed that mission um
that's fun
commanding people
as as arthur kingsley
this mission is pretty it's pretty nuts
uh as well so let's get into it
what are the plans
how's it looking
let's see for yourself
alex says awful game imo oh man
well appreciate you being here if you're
uh
if you feel that way
we can only get there through a horde of
germans armed to the teeth
i think you can handle taking out the
lower gun
i fancy my chances
that bunker's our way in but it's packed
with mgs it'll be a hard push
first job's getting across that
minefield
but that anti-tank dish could be useful
i've got an idea i'm always
we can punch a hole through the mines
with those blitzes there and the bunker
will make minced meat out to us as soon
as they hear the engines coming we're
going quiet then no engines bear the
last second let gravity do the work
that should get us to the ditch at least
well
i love it
i think you should go first
all right then as soon as you hit the
ditch get the men ready
tommy
you with me
oh yeah drive through the minefield take
the bunker strap some thermite to some
highly explosive weapons
piece of piss sarge
and you
get a second sun burning in the sky
if our ships don't see that flare if
they don't know we've won they'll fire
on the guns and risk taking us with them
can't hear it very well okay sorry
a little consolation then knowing that
the fire that killed me was friendly
don't worry go
i won't forget to line up
sorry about that guys i think when i'm
not when we're not balancing my audio
and the game's audio um
the game goes quieter so i turned it up
a little bit but now now i'm afraid i
turned it up too much so just keep me
in the loop about that i appreciate
those comments they're very helpful
thank you that's better okay cool i hope
it doesn't get loud um after i start
firing weapons so here's the plan
there's a minefield over there we're
gonna use this car
as a distraction throw it in the
minefield and raid the bunker let's go
i'm sorry i don't know what time it'll
be available uh
in the in uh in asia
let's go i just threw it in neutral i
guess
okay now is the game too loud please let
me know i don't want it i gotta have a
good balance
have i watched them
no i've not watched that trailer
i don't know what that is
[Applause]
i can just command people and be like yo
[ __ ] up
time
oh that's weird though we gotta move i
guess
we're ready for all this games
[Music]
charge go go go
forward
ah i should have threw a smoke grenade
but i'm out of them
oh no
go go go go go
[Music]
or shot that lantern i think
trench bag i'll take it again let's see
here 20 bullets in the car 98k
brother what a day
hey god i almost shot this friendly
again uh someone has something in the
chat here let me see
okay good sound is good
watching you play this saves me 60 hey
that's cool
keep that money
they need to have a separate multiplayer
yeah that's been a big point of
contention over the years people just
like the multiplayer and they would like
it separately but i don't know i think
it'll always be one pack of everything
i'll take
don't forget the flare let's move up
massage all the way boys this is it you
know me
drag it back we need to clear the door
all right
go they killed my friends over
[Music]
can't believe they killed that dude he
was on my side from the second another
all right where should i focus
gonna are we ever gonna move up
oh i guess we just gotta move up let's
see here see if we can push
every car 98 so far on the ground has no
scope
that's fine it's probably a little
probably a little more released at least
i don't know probably not actually
i know someone in chat can tell me
look at all these goons standing here
beard
at first i thought they were friendlies
because they're seriously just looking
at me like hey what's up
someone in chat earlier said that my npc
comrades are making me look like a star
that's pretty funny uh and i really
believe
oh no
there's too many
okay that guy came from like over here
look at that use the half tracks for
cover
push
i'm the one yelling push and i'm hiding
behind this jeep
can i use the half track
what the like i took it from me hello
oh he said use it for cover okay i'm
gonna pull up i'm gonna roll with this
guy
maybe nope stop moving
too far too far right
no i'm too bad
all right i'm just gonna move up this is
uh
i'm missing my shots i'm way too far
a stupid idea but
well i think that's the first time i've
died that's pretty cool
that's what it looks like to die in this
game okay let me hide here again and
thin out some of the bad dudes
uh i'm on i think regular difficulty
yeah
yeah
i can go i can go hardened um but
for for stream i just went regular
because you know i don't want to keep
dying over and over i want you guys to
see the game
um i did play on
veteran mode for some of the levels
and like the ai is still kind of dorky
they just um
they their bullets hit harder so i was
dying for you know i was still dying a
lot but
the air was still the same
here we go
a little smoke
what the hell
game hmm good can't wait to play it on
ps5 that's great
all right did you pre-order
oh god
i swear this wasn't an issue last time
do i have to be driving this thing
no
i know
[ __ ]
calm down and reload
yeah exactly marco the bullets just do
more damage in hardin and veteran mode
uh but the ai is still like
just as silly as ever
goodness all right let me try another
one of these
maybe a few of these
man something is automatically killing
me as soon as i get up there
dang
akima in the chat in the gamespot
trailers chat it's very nice thank you
i said you are good at sniping um i
don't think so
wait let me see if i can go around
we're all just like waiting everyone's
just waiting for me and that makes sense
because i can command them what to do
sometimes but
let me see what the game wants me to do
reach the uppercase mates okay
goodness gracious
can i drive this nope
this thing's gonna blow up soon i
shouldn't be here for long
okay something automatically kills me i
gotta be careful gotta be ready
man okay i have to figure out yeah mount
the half track i tried um that dude took
my spot and like there's no way for me
to
get on let me try that
yeah it looks like i'm gonna shoot this
guy get him out of my way
no i have to be doing something maybe
this half track is available so i can
thin out everybody
no i swear this didn't happen yesterday
it wasn't so
hard to get past this area maybe this
guy's supposed to move and it's a glitch
that would stink
oh i can shoot them let me uh thin out
the hurt here
yeah it's definitely these guys that are
like
ending me every time but i can't seem to
get around them
that guy looks close so let me try to
hit this guy
i've been able to hit the mg gunners
before i know it's a thing but
can i command them to do anything nope
try picking them off and throwing a
grenade again
yeah i will let's see here that's good
um i'll try to first let me try to just
kill some
more out of my way
and then maybe we'll get like a prompt
you know like okay move up maybe maybe
these mg dudes are killed
i can't hit him
i won
that looked good but i don't think it
killed him
how am i playing early uh
you know we get to review the game and
they uh
they allowed us to play today at
6 00 a.m
so um
that's why i'm here
it's not available you know for everyone
just yet
i think
9 p.m pacific standard time is when
uh you can play your copy if you order
digitally
i think let me see maybe i'm thinking if
i'm not thinking about here let me see
we move around and uh
that's where i was
nope i have to make it up that hill
i swear maybe this thing should just be
moving can i join
can i go
stuff
and it wasn't yesterday like this wasn't
a problem yesterday um
i've already played through this level
you know
damn
now i got really close that time around
there i might throw a smoke grenade
should i get it or not says inc nyc hey
welcome back um
i mean i don't know
i like i i like and i just like being
asked that because you know it's up to
you i mean
if it looks fun to you i'd say give it a
shot but you know i don't want to tell
you how to spend whatever 60 bucks
uh which is why we stream we want
everyone to check it out and
see what they think it won't break my
heart if you don't buy it you know i'm
not selling these games but i do enjoy
playing them and this game i am enjoying
so far
all right i'm gonna try again
i think i automatically get killed but
it's worth a shot
damn it
damn it damn it
check my secondary weapon um
yeah the guy on the mg is probably
glitch should i back okay
i can either
because i think you're right in the chat
i think that this is supposed to move up
and clearly he's not doing jack [ __ ] so
i can either
skip this level because uh i have level
select now i've already beat the game or
keep trying um look at this guy is off
but
he's off he looks he's controlling it
but he's not
uh my secondary is uh
stg
hey let me know what you guys think
should i just skip forward i've already
beat this level and i think it's
currently glitching out i cannot get
through or you know gg richie like get
good
or i can just restart the level also i'm
not that i'm not that far into it i
guess
anyway i don't want to be here for much
longer
you might just try again
maybe we should try to
keep spawning up right here
i want to get to this point where i'm
shooting i want to get behind those
sandbags i think that'll keep me safe
i should be hitting that guy i think
all right wish me luck
go for it again
maybe this will help
not a target that is
i cannot hit those guys
but
normally i wouldn't complain but i hit
him before i've hit mg guys before
there's so many that aren't killing me
it's okay
again they're just making me look good
maybe let me get out of their lineup
site there we go safe over here
i think we're making progress finally
let me see a bar go up um
one ended this morning one lifted this
morning that's how i'm able to play but
i think there's another one for like the
review
the review should be coming later this
week um
done by our very own phil pornshaw
okay
i just need to get like i need to hmm
how should i approach this i think i'm
gonna go left
oh richard g says skip ahead okay if i
if i die
yeah something is automatically killing
me damn it all right well i don't want
to keep you guys on this level for that
long reload
one more time and if it doesn't work
this time i will
i will skip ahead to like the next level
and i can even play you guys the
cutscene because
um
those are safe too when you when you
watch a cutscene in this game it becomes
like savable you can just watch it
anytime you want
going prone helped me last night
again
okay i threw that way too far
i wonder if my team's behind me
sometimes in call of duty games you your
team will not move up unless you do
but i feel like i'm alone here
damn
yeah something's supposed to happen that
mg uh on our side this guy right here
started moving glitched out and then
stopped moving i think he's supposed to
push us forward so let me back out here
sorry it has to be this way but i don't
want to be stuck on that level for that
long i hope you guys understand there we
go
operation tonga that was part there's
like operation tonga is broken up into
two parts we were on the second part we
take the base and then after that we get
this
so i'll just move into this and let you
guys watch we'll move on to the next
level
game only okay
from all the flags waving on the streets
we'd never have known the nazis were
about to lose the war
but bullies are always loudest when
they're scared
and when they're desperate
they get stupid
commander hermann freisinger had killed
novak
they need given us a free ride right
into the lion's den
[Music]
read the field report
twice
this ally team is fascinating they have
been captured
but it was too close
i want you to find out everything you
can about this unit
it will be my pleasure sir
you will speak of this to no one else
and report directly to me
hallelujah
this prison is our battlefield
[Music]
christ what is that smell right calling
dioxide
they think it hides the smell of death
well this is the nicest [ __ ] all i've
ever been in
is anyone else hungry
so
i am happy and fiora
and piss off crowd
unless you've got room service for us
and i have questions for you
yeah we're gonna eat bloody questions
i'm the commanding officer
you'll speak with me
even then richter was easy to read
uniforms had high rank no combat medals
office rat
the perfect mark
surrounded by three guards all armed
and all wankers
in all my years studying the allies i
have never come across such an unusual
unit
kingsley
arthur
lieutenant
service number two five two three two
six four two
i'll tell you a story
i have spoken with sephirah on exactly
one occasion
he recommended a book to me
the passing of the great race
by an american
a man named madison grant
shifura had nothing but praise for him
[ __ ] madison grant
and everyone like him
the book reveals that under extreme
duress
or
unfavorable conditions your people
do not deteriorate so easily
in that moment
i knew what i had to do
right at the super stone lodge
below the clavicle
once we had what we needed from this
racist bastard
that's
where i would put my knife
my plan began to take shape
we were being held in the basement of
gestapo headquarters
around and above us was a treasure trove
of classified nazi intelligence
project phoenix had to be there
somewhere
and richter was our ticket
he thought he was the interrogator
if he was to be of any use to us
he'd have to keep thinking that
that arrogant nazi in his clean pressed
uniform loved the sound of his own voice
the hard part wouldn't be fooling
richter into spilling what he knew of
project phoenix
the hard part
would be convincing the others
not to kill him first
the allies somehow knew about project
phoenix
we must have a traitor amongst the
officers
i pulled their
files take care of them
with the other
non-essentials
lieutenant kings they mentioned a
project phoenix
likely allied propaganda
the negro thought he was protecting his
team
no doubt to prove himself
to make him their leader
the allies must have been desperate
he said it was their first mission
that his sixth man is dead
he's probably lying
i will uncover the truth are there other
teams like this one
how did they learn of hamburg
is temple half at risk of being
compromised these are the things i need
to know
there's more stake here than i'm at
liberty to discuss
just know
that i'm counting on you
here
i understand
thank you
so
uh
well i see 10 fingers
that's a good sign at least don't make a
fuss
i'm fine
listen
they know about weight
they haven't caught him yet
i told him he was killed didn't you
on the train to hamburg
i don't think they'll fall for it but
the hope is it'll buy him some time to
get us out
he isn't coming back for us she's right
kingsley we can't count on that [ __ ]
drunkard
bring out the girl
i'll just get out of my way
all right you guys
it's been a little that was a long cut
scene that's what happens after the
mission that i
couldn't finish this mission bugged out
so
um seeing some comments about
multiplayer and zombies i i'd be i'd be
happy to try those out for you guys um i
didn't because i think the servers might
be a little goofy so
um
i can i definitely can try let me know
just tell me in the in the chat and if
enough people are like yeah give it a
shot then i'll give it a shot um
trip six and gaming says can anyone that
pre-ordered play now no not everyone um
you should be if you pre-order digitally
i think you should be able to play
tonight at 9 00 pm
uh for now i'll just try the stalingrad
mission here um i have i did finish the
game but we're kind of just going in
order which is
obviously yes it's the story so next is
stalingrad this is uh
paulina petrova's first mission let's go
but yeah keep let me know in the chat
maybe after this mission we can try some
multiplayer let me know what you guys
think
this one this cutscene shorter but i'll
be right back
every person on this team was a hero in
their own right
long before their files ever reached my
desk
but to say they were strong
personalities would be
a vast understatement
particularly when it came to petrova
have you seen my
again
it's bad enough i have to wear this
thing at all
no it's flammable
this year's teaching how to shoot
wasted
stuck in a med tent
don't be in a rush to fight dodging
glory is worth nothing
when you are dead but this fight
it matters you matter
you and me
are all i have left
hey
be nice
i'm always nice
alicia
what you got there
empty bottles i'm training fresh
partisans
our cameras already know how to drink
these will be molotovs is it wise to
give explosives to civilians
you're worried
there's my brother misha there's pops
i'm gonna have a seat
oh jesus
you did that well enough
damn
dude's ready
oh there
isn't that nice
real family breakfast little uh
you know you're gonna get yourself
killed having that old rifle in the
house for russia
now who is worried too much
so the germans are approaching the front
line
is that where you're after
no
i told me that's not what i'd be the
most useful so
i'm training recruits at the old poster
resident evil 7 vibes that's funny
the dinner scene nice to have a choice
at least you could definitely don't tell
me at least you watch it
you're both doing your part
which reminds me
if any of those who brutally get past
you
you know where to send them
of course
they will never get through
never
believe this
yes uh call of duty comes out
on the 5th technically you can play it
tonight at 9 00 pm
but
call of duty reached out to us we have
the review code and they said you can
you can stream early so i don't think it
worked it doesn't work for everyone but
we had the opportunity to stream early
so we out here
and you make your old man proud
great so
i am yeah i am uh lady nightingale
sniper wolf basically and uh
germany is
soon invade stalingrad so
uh my brother who just left
uh wants to join the war and he forgot
his molotov cocktails so i have to go
bring him
it's the old chair it's just like she
just talks about memories like this we
should replace your old chair never it's
comfy enough for me but anyway see it
pops i gotta get these back to my
brother
excuse me ladies
there's my brother
[Music]
hello something smells good over here oh
paulina i saved a loaf for your family
you're welcome your father has been
bothering me for some of these yeah okay
gotta go my brother i left him behind
now here he is see look he's trying to
just get on the front lines but they're
like no
i should be going with you you're
probably sure
hey charlie welcome yeah this is the
campaign keep your voice down
you don't want to make enemies here fine
just
don't do anything i wouldn't do couldn't
even if i tried my aim is [ __ ] compared
to you
it's too bad we can trade places that
would look great in that uniform
at least try to make it back from your
bomb making
one piece several pieces it's fine i'm
pretty good at putting people back
together yes
you've made me late again
i'll have to take the rooftops you're
gonna get yourself killed climbing
around out there
i promise you can say i told yourself it
happens
now
go this is war zone
i mean it's about to be a war zone but
uh
okay so my brother there goes my brother
um and i have to check this out every
time you see these yellow tarps that
means you can climb
but it only happens with uh paulina and
her character
paulina drake from uh uncharted i guess
that's nice
beautiful
i'm just i feel like aladdin like
remember in the beginning of the movie
where he's like one jump ahead of the
you know
this lady is not having it so
i'm gonna move away
how is your father's leg finally
improving i keep starting conversations
and just leaving look at all these
little dolls
remember um the matoyska dolls
from uh
you know instead of monkey bombs and
zombies
relax don't worry the red army will
handle it
[Music]
just got people hanging out on the roof
this is kind of cool i've never had
never lived in a building with like roof
access you know um
probably more of a european or even an
east coast thing
uh but if it's anything at all like this
for reals that's pretty cool i doubt it
though you can't go running on the roof
of any building you want
to go ah
anyway yes the campaign is
um it's not live we got to play early so
it's not available for everyone so
uh we wanted to stream and show you guys
what's up hope you're enjoying yeah
assassin's creed that's funny parkour
all that stuff so true
oh her name should be paulina parkour
that's awesome
hammer
all right
the first time i played this i got run
over by that no i don't think it was in
this level but i've been run over by a
tank quite a few times in this game i
think in the uh the australian levels
especially there's a lot of tanks i got
steamrolled
they did this too like when you crouch
um
they have this like see how it kind of
sticks there
it looks kind of buggy when i'm doing it
over and over but that's really helpful
later on like you'll see there's a cool
level where you really have to duck a
lot
and that little transition thing makes
it so smooth
all right reporting for duty
how can i help you
we'll need you down by the first stand
plenty of men that you're catching up
today let's go
oh we're looking at boys
invasion has started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't know if i'd go on the route
like a target but uh that's what's going
on here
is running away
[Music]
here we go here we go
[Music]
yes
oh my
god this
you know what
yikes someone asked in the chat help
your country you saw some frame hitching
i think it is the game and you make your
old man proud
i heard my dad's voice
so that didn't go off thank goodness uh
but yeah about the the frame hitching
yeah i think um
i don't know i have you know my setup
hooked up to the elgato computer and
it usually doesn't hitch i i but i did
notice it this morning good eye
oh crap get back inside me oh oh oh oh
i've already invaded my building
okay
you guys see this
eerie orange glow remember all the i
don't know if you guys were familiar
with all the fires that happened a few
years ago in california but they were
inspired and it's weird to say but
they uh
they made the sky orange
after seeing you know the skies orange
in real life in san francisco it's crazy
oh let's go
i'm going down
hi from south africa hey
are you on a new zealand account no um
you know gamespot.com we're
able to review the game and call of duty
reached out to us and they're like hey
you can play the game early if you'd
like
um so it's not you know it's not
available for everyone
uh but we did want to stream it in case
you guys were interested we're playing
just a little work
uh but yeah it's not available for
everyone just yet um
and uh after this we might try some
multiplayer because some people have you
know access to this game but not
everyone i don't know how the servers
are going to be
ran right into that one
let's see here
what have you done
you have to leave stalingrad now
this game looks better in reality i mean
i guess you're watching a live stream
me playing the real deal i'm enjoying
myself but uh
you know it's all subjective
what is my favorite card game come on
let me jump up here there we go
um
that's that's
i don't know i like a few i really loved
cod 4 of course
modern warfare 3
and like the first black ops that was
like my height
although i love the modern warfare 2019
oh there's my dad in the window that
dude was firing off at the
the nazis below
hang on pop i'm coming can i jump down
yes i can
hang in there pop i'm coming
damn that was a cool slide
60 is a lot yeah that's why you know we
wanted to stream
campaign show off you know
see what you guys think i don't want to
oh no my dad's gone
where is he he was just here nevermind i
know the answer to that
you scum
coming up here
footsteps
[ __ ]
another one dude that would do this camo
now i can't even see
okay
my dad is missing let's see if we can
find him
oh my god i'm reckless being reckless
i did not use this gun very much in
multiplayer because
forever
oh crap being careless
ah
okay
yeah if you guys are enjoying
the stream today here
thank you i appreciate you being here
and all that stuff
we got to play call of duty so early in
the morning this is the first time it's
ever happened so i hope you're having a
good time
as i am
[Music]
man
no
pops
boris
i should have been here
take care of each other
okay
tell mom i'm off to save misha
as usual
okay we're back it's very emotional but
we're gonna do it for pops
uh someone in the chat said they love
the scope on this thing yeah
can't get any simpler than that i love
it it's good it's perfect for like that
medium range you know
and someone in the chat also said relax
man it's like you're playing with your
friends that's really nice uh if you
guys are all at all enjoying this and if
you feel that way
thanks
all right
blind fire no i don't like doing that
the game's like move go go go
is that a bad guy check this out
see yeah
you haven't noticed me
yeah instead of going growing you can
kind of do this half drop this half
crouch and it's like way faster pretty
nice
okay am i supposed to go through there
yeah watch this
i don't know hold on
i feel like they'd give me a prompt to
open this up
oh i just shot it open i was down for
there are a lot of dudes here holy crap
i'm getting hit markers everywhere
holy hell i'm out of grenades
guys already dead don't know why i did
that
saved that bullet for you oh boy there
we go now we got the mp40 yes
yeah exactly review codes i got the
review code you know so we can review
the game and have the review out in time
and then uh call of duty was like hey
you guys want to stream it early
you may you can stream it at 6 00 am and
i was like what let's go that's why i'm
here
you reload this thing
that slide was cool huh dang thanks i
mean that didn't make me feel cool um i
was trying to tell you guys earlier they
have this cool new ducking mechanic that
lets you like it's so much smoother to
duck in between things
um
it's really it's like it's it's it's
never been been smoother at least in you
know single player
man every time there's a bus in the game
it's never good news
other call of duty games have like a bus
where you can hide in remember resident
evil 2 as a bus it was full of zombies
go you went in here
oh molotovs
more molotovs okay
where should i go
it's got to be another way to climb or
something some door oh here we go
i've played through this once just once
um
the entire campaign and it's good
i think i uh
enjoyed myself
someone is running their mouth over here
where we gotta find these people
we gotta get out of town and we gotta
kill everyone on the way out
i hear my brother my brother from my
brother misha is over there somewhere
okay let me
check this out
oh my god
look at look at the distance
i slid just now
oh that had to have been that has to be
broken there's no explanation
that was dope
okay my brother's in the middle of this
room but i have to there's a bunch of
like nazi soldiers walking around so i'm
gonna
you know do some stealth kills
and uh and save them
excuse me
just walk away kill him walk away
i think i will they'll probably see me
let me uh
maybe i won't do that just yet let me go
around
uh but you guys have asked me all
morning like what do you think of the
campaign and i want to know what you
guys think
oh crap
we've been in this for a while now are
you guys enjoying what you see
but you know everyone joins at a
different time so
some of you have been here from the
beginning
somebody stopped in thanks for being
here and last time i did this totally
stealth
probably don't believe me but i did it
entirely stealth and no one saw me this
time i blew my cover
whatever that'll make for
that'll speed things up at least
someone threw a grenade
oh yeah
there's a lot of places to climb in this
level i didn't even see this one before
holy crap it's cool
that's not cool i'm out of here
gotta save my breath i gotta save my
brother
oh crap i thought that man was a human
i thought you had me
okay
let's get rid of these suckers
shut up
crap way too close grenades everywhere
okay
let's focus richie here we go let's go
up
what the hell
there we go
i felt weird it was like the game was
like no don't do that
okay
what's up
hopefully there's not that many left
where'd he go
[ __ ]
that was the smartest ai i've seen all
morning
he just looped he looked around me
okay gotta save my brother gotta see my
brother come on
that was absolute [ __ ] shooting right
there holy crap
i've had a better luck with this this
morning
they are lighting me up i gotta
i was gonna say i gotta get out of here
dude they're everywhere i gotta get out
of
here
gotta fight back
jump
oh god
[Music]
got one that was cool keep forgetting i
have molotovs and not grenades snipe
them okay i'll stick to sniping them
i do enjoy it better but a lot of them
keep coming too close that's why i keep
switching back and forth
sounding like less and less of them good
news
there's one
and a swing and a miss
okay that looked re-focused
silence you
[Music]
friendlies here one more bad dude come
on let's go get him
i will
1v1 him right now in the middle of this
beautiful hall
where is he
show yourself
there you go
[ __ ]
he's dead okay great there's my brother
phew
thanks for hanging in there guys that
was a lot of sniping
shots
i'm right here what are you yelling for
okay it was incredible we're going
hello ivan welcome well i i was so
scared that you and me
you're the one tied up
take care of the others
oh no he's gone
oh no
no misha no we don't have time for this
we have to get your recruits out of here
if we stay here much longer we're
trapped
you're right
you're right
okay
let's go
misha we need to get to the volca how do
we get out of this building
nisha focus
how can we escape i'm back
there's an exit here we could make a run
for the sewers
but the germans are
some enemies only some enemies have you
know
searchable pockets like this
you have any extra supplies weapons
anything i can use i know there were
soldiers defending on the roof they had
the radio there might be supplies too
all right i'll lay down cover fire from
there while you get our people to the
sewers if you're sure sister maybe you
can reach the roof climbing up there
this next part's fun a lot of sniping
but um you get a good vantage point
i should get you to the roof i'll give
you a boost i'll find a good place to
cover you sid hearth says would you call
this game harder than
other cods um
i'd put it like equal maybe
a little easier because the ai is kind
of goofy
he would be proud of you
he would be proud of us
get our people to this door
i'll lay them fire from the roof
yeah i'll try out some other weapons uh
you can't drop the car 98k on this
mission because uh it's like your
father's
sniper rifle
but after this mission um i'll be happy
to try out you know a better or a
different secondary for you right now i
have the mp40 but you know there's tons
of other weapons marina can you hear me
i'm on the radio
i'm not receiving but right now we're
say less dudes
[Music]
okay
unlimited ammo love it i love it
swinomish
that guy alive
[Music]
tons of dudes holy crap
i am but one sniper
i like how they fly
back this thing packs a wall up here
i just shot it
right
in the dome
i should have got this
guy friendlies friendlies who are they
shooting
oh over here holy crap
behind us
how did i miss that
come on there we go that's why i like
the trench mag there's a there's a
magazine okay everyone options
for this gun
of course the one my dad gives me hands
down to me is uh we need a minute to get
the sewer open
okay makes every shot more special i
gotta i gotta be careful with all my
shots here
okay
get up in the windows
shoot
oh up here oh my god
i got the mg's and everything
anyone else
i heard i heard german there we go
guy here one two
three
i think they're trying to flank you on
the rooftops oh crap i forgot about oh
[ __ ]
there they are
trying to sneak up on me i don't know
how my brother saw that from down there
on the ground
nice try suckers
oh one more
right in the shoulder all right yeah
this is single player get down here
play warzone no not yet um i haven't up
god i have uh the only thing i have on
my playstation 5 is cold war modern
warfare workshops
for the latest war zone update so i
don't know what's gonna happen with that
get down to the street okay here i come
i'm gonna pick up the next gun i see
someone in chat was like can you try out
other guns and i would love to i just
gotta uh um let me just find one now
holy crap
uh maybe i should just run for it
i think
i think a counter attack is coming so
let me just get that out of here
okay
we're gonna switch to a cut scene hope
you guys enjoy it we'll be right back
surviving stalingrad was no small feat
escaping
even greater
but no one really escaped something like
that
the nazi war machine had touched all our
lives
burned away something important
i think that's what made us attracted to
the soe in the first place
but for polina
the wound was marrow deep
[Music]
she was destined to return the favor
and that had made her the deadliest
member of my team
[Music]
such a touching story
you couldn't even save the life of your
own father
so tell me
why isn't ivan with an old rifle part of
a top-secret allied operation
you do not scare me
little mouse
you misunderstand me for a line
i do not need you to fear me
[Music]
i need only your screams
that will convince your friends to talk
why
because i am a woman
yes
tell me
what other missions the allies have
in germany
nothing more talking about
so
what is worth talking about
rising
go fetch him
i'll confirm my story together
take her back
send me all the records on a commander
steiner
and any photographs of the russian
sniper
lady nightingale yes is that one
and
yeah freshener i was just coming to see
you
we have confirmation from the woman
the sixth ally is dead
is that so
an american
arrested at temple half
trying to steal a plane
this makes no sense
the prisoners made a fool of you richter
and now you have made a fool of me
the american is being brought here now
if i must interrogate him myself
then i have no use for you
you hurt are you blind
just trying to be nice
what did you tell them
we traded torture tips
relax
i told the same lies as you did he
believe you i stopped asking when i
brought up frysinger
when we get out of here
the first thing i'm going to do
is head to the pictures
see let's
go
let it
break my heart all over again
then you lucas
what's the first thing you'll do when
we're out of here
hey
when i get home
i'm eating lamingtons for a week
all cakes
all the time
i know what you miss yeah
i'd like to have that sweet bird barbara
pull me pints of my local until i forget
the symphony war ever happened
i don't even know if she's still alive
everyone i love is dead
and the only time i feel anything is
when i watch a german beg for his life
so
i am exactly where i need to be
wade showed up just as i'd hoped
he played his part well without even
knowing my plan
that team had written him off
but i was counting on him being his
usual charming self
try that again crowd and we're gonna
have a real [ __ ] problem
your team lied about you
lieutenant
lieutenant
now is that so hard
finally some respect
i know you're the sixth man
what did you want with that plane
you nazis you make me miss fighting in
the stinking pacific
i want to know what else they've lied
about
wade had talked himself out of worse
situations
if you heard him talk about midway
you could tell he was no stranger to
hyperbole
every time wade told the story it was a
little different
he added a wing of zeros or another
aircraft carrier to his tally
but i read the reports about what
happened that day
if wade was exaggerating
it was only by a little
remember our primary objective is
destroying the two japanese carriers vs
and vb squadrons will each take one
fighting squadron six will provide cover
if the weather holds we'll be in and out
before they know what hit them this wind
will give us a pacific
now go out there
and get the carriage
right on you guys
we are back yeah uh those photo
realistic cutscenes are pretty cool
now the entire war's on the line relax
hernandez i was born for this
uh someone's for sure mention
multiplayer um
jackson you gotta let me know if you
guys
uh wanna see multiplayer gotta let me
know in the chat because uh
you know if only one person wants it i
don't think i could switch over i don't
think i should but if a lot of people
want to see some multiplayer i can try i
don't know if the servers are live
though so she would be happy to try just
let me know just you know write
multiplayer in the chat
you never
asked but right now we're playing as
wade from uh
from task force one he's the american
dude obviously and uh
we're gonna fly some planes
and uh there's some dog fighting coming
up
do you think the intel boys got the
fleet position right controls for this
for flying the plane are kind of tough
yeah well i'd rather not be history
today so alexander says definitely try
some multiplayer okay stunts ouch some
multiplayer that would be great okay
great you haven't been promoted yet why
is that smart ass
this isn't the way jackson show um this
is war all of us just want to play with
multiplayer awesome okay you know what
let me stop the heroes off my uh because
um i'll just switch i'll try i'll try
multiplayer i don't know what the
servers are like but i'll be happy to
try
can you look and chat more i'm trying
i'm trying it's hard to you know
put 100 focus on both but
i would love to try
i appreciate you guys in chat you know
so i like to look
multiplayer for sure
okay
oh one person says keep the campaign i
think you know what if multi i thought
of this this morning um i could play
like one mission
and then go to do one multiplayer match
go back to another mission
um if that sounds cool with you guys but
let's see i'll try multiplayer and see
if it works i don't know
if everything is online
fly that plane first damn
okay for sure i think we're seeing a
mixed reaction here and that's cool
because call of duty this year you know
it's got a lot to offer at launch so
let's try
um
let's just try a match quick play of
anything i can try of anything i can
play
um yeah because i'm not the only one in
the world with
early access people were playing all
week because um it was review week we
were reviewing the game and playing it
with hands-on you know and um
uh so people had access to it and some
people those same people like me are
able to play early so there might be a
match but
there might not be either
famous daniel that's really nice
um i haven't post
he's like i'm gonna subscribe um
subscribe to gamespot man that's where
i'm at more than ever because um
i do have a personal youtube but i don't
really use it that much i just put all
my game spot work on there
but you can follow me on twitter if you
want hey we got a match okay cool cool
great
hmm with some really sus
names do y'all think of the game yeah
it's a good question for the chat i
look dumb yes
oh my god
hey all my classes are the way
where the hell do i oh well
i guess
you see how the fov is it's it's set to
100 right now
as you can see i'm much better in single
player but uh
oh man
it's gonna be a lot of dying this is a
lot different than a single player
because uh
i don't know me
oh god that was worth it
it's cool to see that people are online
we can definitely play online
i can't believe dome is bad it's so good
to see
the world that wars don't know
dude slid and shocked me right
this map is always nice
dude
hey we're dressed the same
i cannot dream this is great
i can't
see anything
it feels like i'm playing dome from 2009
all over again
my skill has not increased since
oh you know what i've even noticed we're
playing the hardpoint duh let me get to
the new hardware and maybe play the
actual objective
walls
damn
check
hey look at that and i'm in the hardware
[Applause]
oh this dude is right here
got one
slide cancel please no please don't ask
me
i don't think i technically know how to
do
this
i'll slide and then
i'm sliding
i'll try but
because you know it's a good strategy i
just don't know how to do it
i'm a boomer called
[Applause]
this corner is getting bombed
[Music]
what are the vibes
holy crap
oh [ __ ]
did
yeah the death sound sometimes
it's pretty loud and they're like
they're like
a glide bomb
you're on fire in this game
because it's a flamethrower as a kill
streak and if you're set on fire it's
like ah for like
30 seconds
that's a friendly okay
don't i can't
i wish i could do that for you i'll try
to pull it off but
it's a strat i've never mastered
we won you see playing the objective
killing them killing them
that was cool that's the like post game
pose i forgot what it's called
holy hell
what a flex
oh my god i don't know how i feel about
that i kind of took too long oh you can
vote
this is a democracy
oh i should have i like most defense i
should have voted for that
although this is just that's that's kind
of cool it's new at least i'm i'm
processing how i feel about it
voting ends in 18 seconds dude it's not
that deep like can we move on
can i cancel my phone
speak up for you at a funeral um
no let me see here i didn't know i was
that quiet i keep it kind of low in
general but let's see here
oops i hid your message my bad hold on
view message
damn it sorry i didn't mean to hide your
message someone just said speak up
it's early man i started playing at 6 00
a.m
pacific standard time
and i drank all my coffee
same game every year
that's what someone says in chat you
know what i'm gonna argue
people feel that way
by the masses that's okay
do i have fortnite uh i think on the on
the pc
okay how was that you guys i think i
might do one more match of this and get
back to the campaign but let me know you
know you gotta you gotta
speak to me in the in the in the chat
let me know if you want more
if i can go back to campaign or uh keep
trying this out
razdaz thank you says uh
you sound fine you're not screaming
who's behind you what are you guys
talking about
i can't believe you made me look no
one's behind me
what are the camos like this year you
know what let's back out here and i'll
just show you like
what it looks like i mean if you guys
played the beta it's pretty much the
same but
i will show you the camos
i don't have any unlock because they
they pushed my rank back down
um
the game's frozen there we go
uh camouflage yeah just looks like uh
okay park tactics surgical
uh
they're a little more unique i mean i
don't really you know i don't really
mess with camos that much
um it's funny i like to grind for them
but i don't really even apply them once
i've got them i don't know what that's
about but here they are
oh atomic that's fun
can i preview
yeah that's pretty cool
okay
uh
back to campaign that's cool okay
you guys like uh we were having fun with
campaign we got pretty far um
you know we took a little break played
some multiplayer i'll be happy to go
back into campaign maybe i'll go back
and forth i think that that's like the
best for everyone
so i will go back to zombies is also
here
i have um
we could try that too but i have like
you know
yeah if you guys want let me know i'd be
happy to do that okay here we are battle
of midway
zoom
okay
here we are i'm wade jackson from
you know the us and we're about to fly
our plane finished repairs on the plane
this morning she's waiting for us on the
flight deck
she has a name you name the plane our
plane and you didn't say anything you
never asked
yeah here we go we're back to campaign
thank you guys thank you guys for
letting me know in the chat that's the
best obviously the best way to just
get a hold of me i like to read the chat
this is mateo co-pilot the homie
if we pull this off they'll be writing
about us in history books yeah well i'd
rather not be history today so do us
both a favor and keep the crazy stunts
to a minimum stunts ouch money and
they're like you ever wonder why you
haven't been promoted yet why is that
smart ass cuz this isn't the way jackson
show amigo this is war all of us just
want to win and go home you worry about
keeping the zeros off my tail and i'll
get us home hey the plane's leaving with
that is what the hell
uh how am i liking the game so far i'm
having fun with it um
it's been a crazy week it's nice to
finally talk about call of duty because
i've been playing it all week
you know to capture footage and stuff
for the review and everything and i've
been having fun
i really like the multiplayer uh the
campaign is
up in your bathroom
just remember we're a team up there and
stay in formation this time of the sag
will have both your stripes yeah
formations just slow me down you see
what i have to deal with
look at that
it's a beautiful day for flying
let's hope it stays that way
famous daniel says i'm a hacker
a lady awake [ __ ] says i doubt more
zeros of you jack come on man don't
encourage him here we go
all right
wish me luck friends controlling this
thing it's probably one of the biggest
things i've
had a hard time with is controlling this
plane um
you can turn as much as you want but you
know
it's hard to make sharp turns which is
probably realistic but
it's hard on gameplay hey they're
signaling for pre-flight check
check the elevators in the back
all right elevators are good
okay very good left wing's good
why'd you say that in the chat
this is a certified hood class i can't
believe i'm hearing that in the morning
okay let's get her in the air ready
hernandez guys here we go ready as i let
it be strapped to you
all right here we go full power
controller is rumbling
all right here we are great
no fancy tricks please no fun this isn't
supposed to be fun
yeah
that just means dumbass
no i don't wanna my controls are good
game thank you i don't i don't need that
so you're gonna tell me her name or what
which one the plane this plane you still
hung up on that
well what do you want to talk about
fine keep your secrets
okay i'm out of formation leave me alone
oh my god there we go
holy [ __ ]
goddamn zeros out of nowhere they're on
our torpedo bombers fighters aren't here
yet seventeen get on those bandits i'm
on it you got our tail hernandez all
right guys bear with me
trolls
that sums up this
pretty well
holy crap okay um
turn around here here we go and shoot
some of these zero planes
oh my god
whoa
and better that's great it's true
it's like the if i were to describe it i
would say like the controls are delayed
in flying sections
like
i'm moving to the left to shoot this guy
i'm barely
scratching
but bear with me i put it on regular
mode so i wouldn't be grinding so hard
and like failing over and over
i hope you guys
are enjoying if you guys are if you guys
are enjoying it
gotta leave a like
we've been having a fun morning and
you know what don't leave a like for
that leave a like when i kill a guy
watch this
going around
can't believe they're making me do it a
180
okay back in formation let's go
yeah if you're having fun
appreciate it
those are uh i believe
yeah this is uh
we're getting hit by
aa guns here let's start the dive bomb
i just reloaded
come on here we go
soon i'll be pushing downward we're
going to make our first part
here we go
wish me luck this is hard
it's like
it's kind of it's a moving target and
i'm getting hit with aaa guns watch this
gotta keep it steady
but i gotta avoid the guns
and enemy planes here we go here we go
three
see the red little circle at the tip of
the plane that's my target
so wish me luck
yes
yesterday or the day before when i was
playing this that took me like
legit like seven times
stay low for now boys
yo i'm gonna be getting like air sick
here oh god damn there's so many
sorry this might be hard to watch
because
you guys aren't in control of the
controller of course but uh i'm trying
to try and i'm trying to smooth it out
here i gotta turn around damn it
i'm going where am i going
[Applause]
god i was not meant to be a pilot in any
capacity fictional you're not getting
away incoming reinforcements
you know what aiming down with l2 to do
this
this doesn't help
and whoa
do a backflip with the plane yeah i wish
i could do a barrel roll
holy hell
already
[Music]
can we leave now can we start the
bombing line again
no come on
yesterday
i wish you could use ships says the
truth
not today
i'm turning as sharply as i can got one
on your five [ __ ]
look at that oh
these guys are so fast
oh
checkpoint reached thank god
oh no no no everything's killed down
here [ __ ] or not we've got to climb
oh [ __ ] we're as good as we're dead
today's not the day that's 17 to all
pilots with bombs titan and head up
we're going for the last stop
whoa what well i'm glad
we can't seem to be enjoying it
um
oh my goodness
i think we're going for that
bombing run let's go oh [ __ ] why is it
still shooting at us
paul ass almost out of range
from pacific assault that's what this
reminds you of i never played i never
played that game i don't see him
[Music]
[Music]
take him out
all right here we go wish me luck you
guys
appreciate your patience
oh i think i think i got that guy
don't break formation you gotta punch
through
my pilot wait jackson takes the shield
off i don't know why he gets like a
thrill
out of doing that he only puts the
shield up over him
right now on a bombing run
got him down
the mission were just like this that'd
be much better
because
you're just going in a straight line
altitude links below line up for another
round here we go we need to get that
second carrier who has bombs
s18 has bombs s3 has one
it'll be close enough all aircraft draw
a fire from s17
altitude altimeter's function i think
you better hang on back there
i'm here
feeling steady
this is where i died
check this out
wade would rather have been called a hot
shot than a hero
that was his contradiction
he is one of the wars greatest pilots
but he needed a team
the problem was
getting him to admit
hey guys
don't everybody rush over at once
i'm fine
isn't this a nice little reunion
you lied to me
for all we knew he was dead
so you can [ __ ] off
do really lie to me again
get your hands
what is going on
hitler is dead
what
how
who was it allies
reports indicate he took his own life
but
without the fuhrer
we are lost
hardly
i trust you have new information
as you suspected
the american
was the sixth man
but i believe i have finally broken him
it saddens me
to see the fatherland defile
i feel the irrations
there's nothing left for us here
if the reich is to live on
i must know their safe passage to temple
love
i was counting on you
richter
but you've proven non-essential
no no no sir no i will get you what you
require
i sweat
your time is short
i understand
i'm gonna kill him
the rector is on to us we're out of time
i uh
i tried to navigate away playing but
that didn't work
and by the time i got here you
you guys were already locked up
so i uh
i borrowed a bomb from the rooskies and
turned myself in we got about uh
about an hour before that wall blows
wide open and we waltz right out of here
if we live that long
we can't trust him
he's just a [ __ ] pilot a [ __ ] ace
pilot is what you mean i'm with the lady
what the hell do you know about
explosives yeah well [ __ ] you too then
i'll tell you why we can trust him
here we go
wade's more than capable of getting us
out files in hand
we've got company
[Music]
hang on back there
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[ __ ]
when wade was airborne he was the most
dangerous thing in the skies
but if you fly too close to the sun
eventually
your wings will get burned
you stupid have gotten us both
oh [ __ ]
all right
okay
i'll get you out of here but it's gonna
hurt like how
hey hey wade why are you stay with me
wait come on man don't get up wake up
wake up wade on no today's not the day
i need to find out where we are so i'm
gonna have to leave
you think about the yankees
all right
you know i'm a doctor
son of a
your bedside [ __ ] sucks you're welcome
pendejo ah
i need your gun
i
lost mine in the crash
the one you caused
what am i supposed to do
keep yourself bandaged up
i don't want you bleeding out and
missing all the fun
they got a sight till i get back
what's up you guys i'm back
hope you enjoyed that cutscene got some
comments that were like yeah remember
when games were uh you know
games and not pixar movies
this one for a call of duty game has a
lot of cutscenes though i'll give you
that
uh but now we are backing away from this
mess i was impaled
i'm weak and weaponless
i have no idea where my friend went
so wish me luck i think this will be the
last uh campaign mission we play for the
day so let's bring it all in let's enjoy
and i really appreciate you guys being
here had a lot of fun streaming this
this morning and i hope you enjoyed
but this mission
is pretty cool wade has a super power
there it is
he can focus and like basically like
wall hack check this out
there we go
it's really good when you have a weapon
but i don't have one yet i gotta i gotta
take this guy's
weapon who's richie's
that's me
that's uh that's my name on on twitter
and
um that's my face in the comments that's
me
with the oh yeah with the wrench uh i'm
an admin of course for game spots
youtube
all right oh no that was my friend
matteo screaming they caught him they
caught him
i'm coming buddy so wish me luck let's
go find mateo and let's get some weapons
and stuff
okay
i forget what these are called but these
are clever these little traps
or places to hide
come on let's find somebody
there's a group of them over there but i
just need this guy's weapon
got him
of course he only has six bullets to his
name
all right
when i first played this i've played
through the entire campaign but when i
first played this i actually got lost in
this jungle so i might use the waypoint
like this
uh there you go see the white waypoint i
swear i got lost it's easy to get lost i
can't believe it normally call of duty
maps
aren't that big in campaign and i got
lost i felt like a loser
but uh here we go now i got a gun in
hand ready to roll
man
he saw me it's
over that dude was charging me
dude was mad
here we go
damn right away
last time when i did play this it took
me forever because i was being stealthy
and i didn't get caught once but
i don't know
having fun here we go
but um yeah there's no silence weapons
of course so maybe i'll be a little more
careful
or at least wait till i get more ammo
yeah daniel when uh when a cutscene
comes on i still want to chat with you
guys so that's me richie's in the chat
how long is the campaign um
someone asked us earlier i think you
know the way i play call of duty games i
try to i try to take my time and you
know find intel and all that stuff so it
took me like
i think
five and a half six hours like which is
regular call of duty uh
to me
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
but you know there are more cut scenes
this time
that's for sure
they're nice though the pre-rendered
cutscenes are really nice
okay sneaking away sneaking away where's
mateo there we go
yeah you guys have been here for a while
let me know what you think of the of the
campaign so far we've seen a [ __ ] we've
seen a
variety of levels
come on where is he where is he i'm
being extra quiet
like on the mic
sorry
where'd he go
what
i'm using my focus right now i should be
able to see there's one guy okay
okay he just walked away
i don't think i should have used focus
right there
[ __ ]
[Applause]
goodness gracious
you know what kind of stinks um
i can't adjust the fov slider in single
player
we played a one match of multiplayer on
dome and um
it felt like i was flying is this guy
asleep or dead
oh he's dead oh yeah i killed him wait
didn't i no this thing was closed
goodness i don't even remember
five hours after three years of
development yeah um
i guess that's a that's a good point i
think i think though
in my honest opinion i thought about
this yesterday i think
they intentionally keep call of duty
games short like they're fun action
flick style
movies uh that look great that that
takes a lot of time but i think it's on
purpose like be honest would you would
you want to play
like a you know
15 20 hour call of duty game that i
might but i don't think everyone would
but let me know
and he and offering the units within
range of this transmission lieutenant
wade jackson requesting immediate
support
any americans on this damn rock
no luck with the radio okay
[ __ ]
they're right here
already have us
seven bullets
huh
how many bullets were in this thing i
might pick it back up okay i'll take
this
for now i guess
crap
[ __ ]
excuse
me i'm out of here bro
mateo
honestly zombies is dead for this game
just watched your videos
i don't know
i just watched videos of it
yeah zombies should be functioning right
now um
i don't i played it
once and got to level 10.
it was it was okay i need more time with
it for sure and they're definitely gonna
you know at launch it might be kind of
bare bones but
they're definitely gonna work with uh
treyarch and zombies they're gonna blow
that story up so i think we might just
have to wait
until it gets like really good at launch
um the one map they do have is pretty
cool
i tell you i'm going the wrong way okay
there we go
i'm just gonna get out of here there's
uh i'd rather not fight oh crap
i'd rather not fight and then i knifed
this guy in the throat well he was in my
way
there's two of them here i'm just gonna
keep going to mateo mateo was my
co-pilot we lost him he went to go get
help
we're stuck on this rock together
these aren't tunnels i keep forgetting
that they're just a little [ __ ]
i'm out of here bro
yeah they're firing dammit i blew my
cover
[Music]
angry
so mad
two for one very cool
who's left
oh yeah when you do the focus mode you
go into auto aim that's crazy
of course no one else is around
oh those two guys are
i think they're too far away damn it
okay
well get away
i heard mateo he was screaming did you
guys hear that
wait that one had a bayonet i will
definitely take that back
oh [ __ ] i'm pulling around too much
fooling around too much
okay check this out now that i have a
full auto gun let me show you ways of
building it's open
wow didn't feel that op this time
normally it sticks there it goes
it like it seriously went to you
remember red dead redemption when you
can like pick your targets and scan
between each of them that's what it felt
like
getting lit up
still oh my god oh my god i'm dead i'm
dead i'm dead
i'm toast
yeah i'm dead damn it you got me
how do i get early access um
that we were you know we review the game
so we've had the code for a little bit
and then call of duty reached out to
gamespot and they were like hey if you
want to stream early
go ahead you can start at 6am today so
we started at 6am
um you know just uh because we've had
our coffee for a while now
anyone else any questions
boom you're out wait there's more coming
what the
those are people over there
oh that was a much better run this time
how we doing chat wait people can play
now no not exactly some people can you
know we've had the code
so we can review the game
but uh
you know everyone else will have wow
look at this guy what are you waiting
for everyone else will have the ability
to play i think starting at
9 00 p.m tonight pacific standard time
that guy was seriously just looking at
me i couldn't believe it
uh well here we go moving on let's find
mateo man he is
around here somewhere
i was going the wrong way
hmm
there's nothing ever in those
planes that's not our plane oh must have
been one of the japanese pilots
just curious does it feel very linear or
is there some user freedom in the space
in this level there's user freedom but
it i just got lost like um
it's maybe
it's maybe a little a little less linear
in some levels but overall i would say
it's very much it is very linear call of
duty style you know they and if you ever
get lost you just hit this button [ __ ]
one more over here i think
got it backed away from my mic because i
was scared like where are they at where
they at
nope got them all
for now
hang on buddy potato yes he's just down
this hill check this out
oh i hit my head on the trunk
there he is mateo is alive he's on the
right
i'm sorry the left oh my god thank
goodness yeah he's on the left
[Music]
today
i'm having fun though
and i hope you guys are too that's the
point of the stream i wanted to show
uh the campaign and
some multiplayer to you guys a little
earlier
i think this is a cutscene let me back
out if it is
no no it's not okay
kind of it's like an in-game cutscene
enjoy
do you speak japanese
[ __ ] up
they're still alive yeah
no [ __ ] got them free from aviation
machinists made third class hernandez
the ungrateful ones lieutenant jackson
we got shot down that's why we're here
thanks
sergeant james washington army 93rd
infantry division lenny
this man up you got any planes
we need to get back up there flames
we lucky they gave us ammo
that one's dead weight
just going to slow us down
i'm right here
you know how to use a gun went through
basic just like you started company
i got control of stick now lieutenant
you're just
okay we're back in it these these dudes
i forget what uh
like what regiment they were called like
the 96 or something they they found us
and they are in control
did you guys recognize howard he was
from uh
call of duty world war ii
oh yeah focus check this out you guys
oh my god the camera shifts so crazy
it's like red dead redemption i'm
telling you oh that's a friendly that's
mateo
just going to beast mode you don't care
all right it's over
oh i don't have my car 98 no more oh
well
there we go
they're running away they're running
away
whoa i heard the flamethrower
awesome
he's right there howard uh
lewis howard
dude is fortunate
jason p i jumped in a few minutes ago
are there vehicles for this and are
there vehicles in multiplayer um i've
only played a few maps in multiplayer
and i didn't see any
but there are 20 maps and uh i mean
maybe i wish i could tell you for sure i
didn't get to play every map though
i want that uh
flamethrower
hey
you guys said you were 93.
never heard of him yeah 93rd bet you
ain't never met a negro before neither
we ain't exactly in the credit getting
business
oh
the coloring regiment
yup you see any snakes or centipedes let
me know we'll get the cookout
howard's got jokes
here we go
um i think this is
oh yeah this is a this bridge is kind of
a big deal all right
went up dog says this looks really good
i'm i'm surprised all right good stuff
man
glad you're here too thanks for being a
part of the stream today we got to play
call of duty a little early
uh if you pre-ordered i think you can
play tonight at 9 00 p.m but uh call of
duty reached out to us and
feel free and people who had early
access and we're like hey
you can see me yeah there's a sniper for
sure i got it
that guy was good
um they were they were talking about
what to do so i'm just gonna listen this
time
that sniper got thompson he was on a
bridge just like this so how do we cross
is it okay if i leave daniel please of
course thanks for being here for so long
appreciate you feel free
your name's up
hope this grit's in heaven
life bait you volunteering hell no then
shut your mouth and keep those eagle
eyes on the counter
then shut your mouth that's great oh no
yep confirmed smoke
when i get a word i want to see your
best jesse owens oh
please run [ __ ] fast
let's go let's go let's go
these sniper shots sound good in the
headphones
we need to get to that tree line into
the grass and stay low
regroup under the trees if you make it
to the other side
yo
[Music]
[ __ ]
oh okay okay we got we got a location
somewhere up here
oh more of them yo i gotta hide better
oh i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead
i'm dead i'm dead
the man survived the great war and jim
crow
is he up there
shooting like an idiot into the wind
oh
louis i was like why can't i move louis
howard was in my way
i feel like i'm shooting a coconut oh i
see him
oh my god
god i've got one
okay there was only one
these crazy [ __ ] trapped
themselves up in trees
what are we doing out here anyway
brad shipped in the 93rd to help the
23rd take this rock
it's japanese base not far from here
it's protected by a hollowed out ridge
the rest of my boys are stuck behind a
locked door
and we're the key
what the hell does that mean
jason you're you're muting
he muted so he can take a zoom call
hey man that's life it's only uh it's
thursday you know
but this will be the last mission you
guys as soon as we
see the end of this
dodge a bullet by sliding man i'm not
that good
clearly you saw me get hit a million
times
oh i sprayed
like nobody's faces
[Applause]
[Music]
i just hear people getting torched out
there this is nuts
don't look at me
got him
that one dead
that one isn't
there tons of dudes here
oh i saw him as soon as
guess not damn out of bullets
oh no
oh no help me out howard where are you
at with the flamethrower oh here we go
wow i don't think i've picked up this
gun in the game yet
cool
[Music]
oh wow this reticle
system
this aiming system's
weird
oh that's disorienting
not that much i guess but uh are we
playing this in multiplayer
that'd be different
how do you play early uh this is a
a review copy of the game you know
gamespot.com will be reviewing this game
soon and we've been playing it all week
so
we've had the we've had the game and
activision and call of duty they were
like uh you can stream early today so
that's that's exactly what happened but
for everyone else who ordered it
especially if you ordered it
digitally
you can play tonight at 9pm you can play
it a little early but
we got like early morning access at game
spot today so we decided to stream to
john adams we could use the help
we'll do what we can
don't get us
oh i tried to slide and it just went
prone that was
dumb nazis and japanese
her boys so
well
hitler ain't got nothing on mama
is that the rich
that's the one
oh this uh
what is it the type 11 is pretty cool
looking
you can't inspect
uh um weapons in this campaign mode
makes sense why would you want to do
howard you're a dragon
once we clear the wire we'll be under
heavy fire
i need you to turn up the heat on these
bastards you got it sarge
ping yeah the classic m1 ping a word
the site is purposefully enlarged
it says chat says marco yeah
you're going to help private howard get
that wire
and then
you're going to keep him covered on the
other side understood
look
in the sky i'm your man but this
i'm not the die face down in the mud
then you shouldn't have got yourself
shot down
oh that's good
there's a difference between suicide and
sacrifice
you do well and learn it
damn set me straight
low and quiet boys
low and quiet boys he said okay let's go
jackson to the left the rest of you on
me
oh man look at all these these have been
here for a while it's
sorry i'm not i'm not crouching like the
rest of them
i'm like where are we headed
jackson
jackson i'm jackson yeah okay
here we go
we got your hands dirty
after you
yeah truth says anyone in cod anyone
that says cods graphics haven't changed
is blinded with hater glasses
oh he's stuck
come on come here oh
okay
oh goodness
let me go around that
here what the hell
what
okay here it comes oh no he's stuck okay
now he's stuck for reals let me help
jackson help
god i don't even consider [ __ ] like this
like
of course he would get stuck
carrying that big old thing around
[Music]
all right
they gave me the phone fellow right on
one up dog
you know what i got the type 11 and i
have closed
nope not shooting through that oh there
we go
too much too much
he dodged the bullet did i
did i dodge a bullet while sliding like
he was requested
yeah what am i doing
board
oh they're running away
we all going
and i have some gusts charging me when i
have a flame thrower
but we did it i think we cleared the
hill right what's this
okay i like my gun so far so i'm going
to keep them for now
yo okay guys they're taking care of them
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
that guy i think he uses bayonet on me
damn
evan langer yeah this is the new leaf
sonic game actually
uh shadow the hedgehog part two
bring it on
okay i'm not gonna let that guy bang at
me again
that was harsh
let's go let's go
wrong kind of let's go but you know
yo
wow i didn't even recognize that guy's
the enemy
nailed them
there we go they got him this time oh no
they didn't
that's the guy who killed me last time
see ya
almost there
instead go go
[Music]
did i tell you guys i think i did
multiplayer when you get hit with the
flamethrower your character screams for
like 30 seconds it's like
all right
let's get to the ridge clear the ridge
i know i can shoot through here watch
this
or punch through it it's probably
goodies up here
nope it's just the way out
oh damn it a shot oh
you guys evan was just kidding
evan knows i i
love sonic
but he's
he's clearly kidding
no this is
patrick come on let's go
i have yeah i do have something here
let's go
you know what
switch to the
sdg or type 100 i think i'll go uh type
100
pick it up
yeah
no that was a bad choice already i
regret it
there we
go okay team we're heading to the
airstrip that's the last part of the
mission
that guy did not want to die there we go
[Music]
that was close
there was a guy in here
come on there we go
great
well let me know you guys have been here
for a while i like hearing from you what
do you guys think of the campaign so far
did you guys just jump into the chat or
have you been here all morning with me
let me know i'm curious you guys like to
ask me what i think and i'm having fun
so far but you guys are the ones
watching so let me know what you think
time to load up here and i think we're
gonna make our final push
time to destroy these
[Applause]
belfry shoot the flare let's see him
stop us now are you [ __ ] crazy why
would you fire that
you just gave the entire japanese army
our location the invites not for them is
for the rest of my men
right on schedule
come take a look at this
[Applause]
here come my voice all right
check out the hangar
near the radio tower
hanger near the radio tower there it is
that's our way out man val dive bomber
you know anyone can fly this was your
plan all along
my man can take the base
slow down the japanese but if we had
someone in the air
wouldn't that be something i'm your man
sergeant
i was hoping you would say that
let's get down
do you even know how to land that thing
when's that ever stop me
let's go regroup with the tanks
all right
yeah truth says i like it all right good
stuff man glad you're enjoying
the game so far and the stream thanks
for being here
push down the hill all right here we go
time to get serious
seriously lit up there's too many people
here
i think it's time for my uh ability
wade jackson has this ability
check it out
it's incredibly op
i'm even shooting my aunt my friends
okay i should have pushed this forward a
little more
i don't have a secondary i think my
flamethrower went away not cool
oh well
let's pick up something else
okay
camp out here let's see anyone else yep
i hear more of the soldiers talking
they're over here
all right let's push
that guy's dead
we're doing it we're pushing let's go
let's go
there's our team all right
i forgot to cancel my vanguard amazon
shipped my copy dang oh that's a weird
problem to have and hopefully
maybe i'll change your mind or you know
you can always return it
oh no they keep shooting from the right
a lot going on over there
okay there's the hanger behind the tank
i'm going for it
what oh
is that a friendly am i completely
unloading on a friendly
it was god he even has blood on his
helmet i'm such a terrible
all right enough let's get to the plane
the hangar's just ahead
wow wow wow wow this is embarrassing
although i did knock that guy out
[Applause]
oh
this will be fun
we're here
oh man no one's even around
there's one guy
all right guys i'm close i'm close to
the hanger steal the plane in fact i
passed the hangar what am i doing
oh i didn't pass again
let's go
it's the final push there's quite a few
of them let's get through
i'm making a run for it okay i heard
that i heard that
yo what is this
no time
[Applause]
what
that dude was all gillied up
we made it
all right i'll let this play out you
guys i'll be right back
we'll push you out of the hangar
take this cover us while we get you in
position
find us some runway and we'll handle the
rest
never mind i forgot about this part one
more final one more push here and then
it'll be the cutscene then i'll back out
so you guys can see it
i can't tell these little uniforms
they're tan
ours are green okay all i got
it's like army man 3d you guys remember
that game
that keeps shooting
okay here it comes well i wonder if i
use watches if i use focus mode while
taking down this plane
it works
oh god
nice
they're pretty bad at hiding
they usually are call of duty games here
we did it
couldn't have done it without this team
won't be eating this anymore
show us what you can do lieutenant
all right
let's see
do we have enough runway yeah
more or less i should have known you'd
say that
here we go
[Music]
stay behind the tank
[Music]
thank you
come on let's go
[Applause]
the men of the 93rd
changed wade they showed the flying
daredevil from the clouds
what war looked like in the dirt
down there
he learned the only way to win was to
have each other's backs
if you get past this talk and you see
his actions
you know
who way jackson really is
i don't care what he did before
okay you guys that was the end of the
midway mission so i'm gonna back out
here wait
i'm going to back out here oh my god
oh my god stop great
and i want to thank you guys for joining
me on the stream it was a cool
opportunity to stream it so early in the
morning oh look what mission is next
uh but really appreciate you guys being
here um
it's always fun to stream call of duty
and i hope that you enjoyed and i hope
that you get your copy soon and you're
able to play it if you um
if you ordered it digitally you should
be able to play tonight at 9 00 p.m
pacific standard time we got to play
early just because we've had the code
and
call of duty gave us the okay to stream
it early
so we went through a lot here i hope you
guys enjoyed
and be on the lookout because our call
of duty review will be up soon we've
also got more gameplay footage
as well as you know continued coverage
about call of duty so if you had a fun
time drop a like really appreciate you
guys being here you guys were great
and uh it's hard to operate so early in
the morning but you know we did it and
[Laughter]
and uh it was fun it was all for you
guys so
thank you
have a have a good day enjoy call of
duty uh if you get your hands on it and
i'll see you guys next time take care